now you're a [ __ ] decent guy
you don't get in any [ __ ] you're not
involved in any brawls you don't get
involved any stupidity you're an
excellent representative of a
professional athlete Thanks
what do you think about all this Conor
McGregor [ __ ] you see someone
throwing a Dahlia Tomas and shattering a
window that's no I don't even have words
for it man
I'm the word for it what did you think
of when you heard that I heard the news
when I landed I was in the plane when it
was all happening flying to New York and
when I landed my phone was like all
these text messages coming in going what
the [ __ ] is wrong with Conor what the
[ __ ] I'm like what happened you know and
then I checked the news and I was like
oh Christ and then I hear that two
fights were pulled from the card then
three fights were pull the card not what
Conor McGregor he he's just he's just
losing it right now it feels like he's
lost it I feel like yeah you know I
never really been you know I respect all
these things these does he's he's a he's
a great businessman he'd do what it
takes to make money he knows what it
takes to get money and he does he did
really good he's easy he's a mastermind
when it comes to trash-talking man
whether he takes it to another level but
like this thing he did now it's just
it's it's just crazy you don't do that
you don't do it at all I don't I don't
know water is why he's doing it yeah I
don't know either
he's drunk as [ __ ] or is he is it just
booze
I wouldn't think that's a booze moved
that seemed more like a coke could be I
don't know just could be part of his act
yeah but that's the thing like do you
really take it that far you didn't take
it that far to just make some noise I
don't know what if my thing is like what
if that that dolly hit the car where
Rose was sitting and cut roses face up
no that was just beer that's like crazy
michael Chiesa I'm sad that he got kind
but jess is a tough bastard it'll be
fine he's probably pissed off and it's
gonna sue Connor and I probably make a
shitload of money soon yeah but what if
it hit Rose no that would be bad no Tara
the [ __ ] world would hate him oh yeah
oh yeah Rose
was blinded to one eye because Ray
Bourque got cuts in his eyes yeah it's
it's entirely Pisces that's glass cuts
in his own yeah yeah he got glass shards
he got a scratched cornea or they also
know it should be I don't find out how
many lawsuits
I know chiesa filed chiesa definitely
filed a lawsuit or filed a complaint
which will lead to a lawsuit I imagined
look I've matched if I was Connor I
would settle the [ __ ] every single
thing outside a court because if he
loses if he loses and he gets a felony
he's [ __ ] he probably won't even be
able to come into the country no exactly
no here's my thing imagine switch it
around imagine of reborg through that
dolly at the bus and Connor yeah he was
smoke be gone he will be gone for sure
that's one of the more [ __ ] up things
about the yeah yeah he will be gone is
that you know Connor is getting special
treatment excite of course yes yeah of
course of course that's not good for
anybody no it's not it's not and like I
told you he's just he's just losing his
mind right now it's yeah you do it to a
certain certain level and then you just
like you just chill you don't take it
further than that then what it just did
so I don't have any words for it man I
just feel like it's terrible it's
terrible for for everybody in the sport
man though it's terrible it's terrible
for Connor even he's making money I
don't know what it makes what it made
for that may with the fight I'm telling
you if you keep doing what he's doing
that that that money is not gonna be
enough no to pay all the [ __ ] he has to
pay no no he'll burn right through that
well he's probably burning through that
money anyway every time you seem he's
got a new Bentley
yeah probably lives in a mansion now oh
yeah he does under percent yeah yes it's
private jet I don't know how many
bounces I don't know you him any good
what you call it buddy Garcia had when
he hit that guy in Ireland the the the
gangster guy he island he had a bunch of
like bodyguards I heard around but they
cost every day not cheap tough yeah that
money piles up yeah but when you're 29
years old like Connor you don't even
think about it no you're doing he's
thinking about now not the future and he
probably thinks he's gone
in support of it man as I said because
do what is doing whatever is a billion
or whatever it is it's not a lot of
money it's gonna run through you well
there's that and then there's the thing
that really gets me is that what Connor
is is an exceptional world championship
fighter I mean that's what he really is
all this other stuff is the the [ __ ]
is gonna get in the way of his legacy I
mean he his legacy shouldn't be a boxing
match where he's TKO'd by the greatest
boxer ever that's [ __ ] stupid yeah
and his legacy should be the next fight
after India I know what you mean man
that was a match he's been smashing
beasts yeah it's been taking two birds
he's a he's a he's just a regular guy
from Ireland it comes to this it comes
to America he just lives the American
dream he you know it don't think
nobody's done before so you know it's
it's terrible it's terrible to see all
this [ __ ] happen yeah cuz I'm saying
that all these things that are happening
it's bad for him yeah of course it's not
just bad for the sport to let him get
away with it with all this happening you
don't even like think of what has been
doing in the Octagon right exactly
exactly I mean just think about setting
him up with khabib you know having that
fight like jesus [ __ ] christ that
would be a giant fight that might be one
of the biggest MMA fights ever to make
him versus kabhi kabhi B's what's his
record 25 no 26 96mm 26 amazing and he's
barely tested yeah it's tested yeah
that's amazing you see one little flaw
on him you get all excited yeah cuz like
who look he's keeping win that fight
what's up who do you think we in that
fight it's a good question it's well if
the question is can Connor catch him can
kind of catch him on he's coming in yeah
and if Connor can catch him what Connor
can knock anybody out yeah I mean you
see what he did to Eddie Alvarez you see
what he did to Aldo nobody had ever done
that's Aldo before this well that that's
the best strikers in the division yeah
and what Connor has is incredible
precision man dia busy he's but his face
he's so fast so fast he speed his angles
he moves he moves create an angle and he
just countered the [ __ ] out of the guys
and
yeah that's that's all you need she also
moves unusual he was almost like a
karate guy yeah he does you know wide
stance but then knocks you out like a
like a real boxer like the only thing
I'm doubting its own corner yeah you
know he's East best striker and all of
that but does he had the condition if
you kaboom
that's a good question she just he just
keeps going in just an animal
yeah and it's also the wrestling yeah
but Kobe was wrestling is not just a
level above everybody else but multiple
levels yeah he just I heard I heard like
heavy guys I'm talking about
heavyweights talking about Kobe's
pressure on the ground be on top yeah
yeah taking that that cyber that seat
belt around taking his hands moon that
leg you trust the guy totally so Luke
Rockhold said he never loses around you
training oh he said he said he doesn't
lose around yeah could be he doesn't
lose around he just smashes everybody
that's the same everybody who wrestles
time to go through the grinder so